from basketball now to golf this morning
celebrities are out and they're ready to
take on the Viva Las Vegas golf
tournament and we are expecting some big
announcements from the LPGA as well and
some exciting performances our Candace
Charles joining us live from the Valley
High with how the golf season opener
entertains but Candace also gives back
that is absolutely right Heather good
morning to you good morning folks now
today you can expect to hear some
performances here at Bali as well as
seeing some LPGA icons right now I'm
joined by the Hilton Grand Vacations
Vice President Aaron Stewart now I know
you guys have a lot going on as far as
the tournament champions what can people
expect this year around yeah so first
and foremost it's a great way to start
off the year right we're the third week
of January and it's really a celebration
of the accomplishments of some of the
LPGA Professionals for them to qualify
for our event they have to have won an
official LPGA tournament in the previous
two seasons and so it's a fun way to
kind of get kicked off for their year
there's no cut for them they're playing
alongside the celebrities it's a little
bit more Carefree I would say until that
final uh final final stretch of holes on
Sunday then they're in game mode for
sure but it's a it's a really fun
exciting way to start the year off now
as the son of icon and Payne Stewart I
know that you've seen how huge of an
event this is getting right into the
golf season tell me a little bit about
that how everybody are feeling that day
yeah well you know for me personally to
be back in golf and with Hilton Grand
Vacations It's the Best of Both Worlds
right I grew up after college after my
competitive golf career was it was
finished I went straight into the
corporate environment and it's been
great to be able to to get back to that
and kind of have the two coincide with
each other I know you guys are helping
some youngsters as well get involved in
golfing with this event that's the
amazing part of it we'd love to see that
so tell us a little bit about the chair
that you're working for this year yeah
one of our brand ambassadors is World
Golf Hall of Famer Annika sorenstam and
so we've been partnered with her and her
foundation the Annika foundation and
it's been a fantastic partnership they
do a great job of really empowering
young female Junior golfers to get them
prepared for the next step whether that
be in the game of golf or in the
corporate environment so they're doing a
lot of great things and we're really
proud to be a partner of them and today
will just be a little taste of what we
can expect at the Tournament of
Champions as well and I hear there's
going to be some great musical acts
exactly yeah so we're really excited
we've got Michael Ray tonight and then
Joey Fatone and Joey always brings up a
few of his celebrity friends and
musician friends to come play with them
so really excited awesome Aaron thank
you so much for chatting with us this
morning have a great time all of it
kicks off today at 10 o'clock and of
course you can find out more details
about the tournament Championship that's
going to be happening in January on our
website eightnewsnow.com Heather a lot
of fun stuff happening there Candice we
appreciate you